[Música]
con el paso de los días va escalando la
atención diplomática entre Guatemala y
Colombia después de que el país
centroamericano diera a conocer su
intención de poner en marcha una
investigación contra el actual ministro
de defensa de Colombia Iván Velázquez
recordemos los principales hechos de
acuerdo con el gobierno de Guatemala la
investigación contra el ministro
colombiano tiene lugar en el marco de
una investigación del caso odebrecht
recordemos que el ministro Velázquez fue
también jefe de la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad en
Guatemala la sisic entre los años 2013 y
el año 2017 la sisic fue una comisión
creada en el año 2006 y fue disuelta en
el año 2019 surgió como parte de un
acuerdo entre el gobierno de Guatemala y
la organización de Naciones Unidas era
una entidad independiente que debía
apoyar al ministerio público también a
la Policía Nacional civil y a otras
entidades del Estado guatemalteco en
investigaciones cometidos por cuerpos
ilegales de seguridad y también por
grupos clandestinos en esencia buscaba
fortalecer la justicia en Guatemala para
que ellos más adelante pudieran
enfrentar escenarios futuros en el área
de Justicia durante sus años de
funcionamiento la comisión impulsó casos
en los que unas 680 personas fueron
implicadas en diferentes casos entre
ellos hubo varios funcionarios del
gobierno guatemalteco y también
destacados empresarios de ese país
centroamericano ganó 310 condenas y
desmanteló unas 60 redes criminales
el fiscal de Guatemala Rafael
curruchiche Indicó que Velázquez debe
responder por actos ilegales por
arbitrariedad y abusos escuchemos sus
palabras puntualmente ante los hechos
evidentes en los cuales quedan de
manifiesto actos ilegales y corruptos
que causaron grave detrimento al Estado
de Guatemala la fiscalía especial contra
la impunidad categóricamente manifiesta
que no escatimará esfuerzo alguno para
que quienes resulten responsables rindan
cuentas ante la justicia y paguen por
sus actos con todo el peso de la ley
Velázquez después de su paso por
Guatemala genera opiniones divididas en
ese país centroamericano a raíz de su
trabajo en esta comisión entre sus
trabajos más destacados estuvo pues el
haber liderado una investigación que
terminó con la dimisión del presidente o
entonces presidente de Guatemala Otto
Pérez Molina en el año 2017 el ex
mandatario recibió una condena de 16
años por casos de corrupción Velázquez
fue cesado de esta comisión
internacional porque así lo decidió el
entonces presidente de Guatemala Jimmy
Morales quien decidió también poner fin
a esa comisión internacional
ante estas acusaciones y decisiones del
gobierno de Guatemala la contraparte
colombiana respondió por supuesto como
era de esperarse así lo hizo el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
desde la ciudad de davos en Suiza en
donde asiste al Foro económico mundial
el mandatario respaldó por completo a su
ministro defendió la dignidad de ese
país suramericano y pidió respeto para
Velázquez y para él como mandatario
pero nuestro ministro de defensa se
respeta y el presidente se respeta
nosotros no vamos a rodear la soberanía
nacional ante una acción corrupta
provenga de quien provenga y se saben ya
los nombres exactos etcétera lo que
estar es vengándose de una acción que
iba contra la impunidad tomada por
Naciones Unidas no por el gobierno de
Colombia pero con un ciudadano
colombiano al frente que merece todo el
respeto por su accionar esas venganzas
de politiqueros y de corruptos nosotros
no la vamos a aceptar más cuando
intentan vulnerar la soberanía nacional
ya lo ven ustedes la atención entre los
dos países está presente ambas naciones
ya convocaron a sus respectivos
representantes diplomáticos a consultas
Pero entonces puede trascender esta
atención entre los dos países
latinoamericanos porque Guatemala hasta
ahora inicia una investigación contra
Velázquez Cuáles son los argumentos Y
cómo debe ser el manejo que le debe dar
Colombia a este caso dado el caso que
Velázquez se ha encontrado culpable o
inocente o que trascienda esta
investigación allí en Guatemala la
atención entre Guatemala y Colombia es
nuestro tema de debate y análisis hoy en
el debate de Francia 24 y para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado a
Stephanie Rodríguez internacionalista
abogada enfocada en temas de Derechos
Humanos ellas se encuentra en ciudad de
Guatemala Guatemala y desde la ciudad de
Bogotá en Colombia se conecta Alejandro
Godoy él es consultor geopolítico en
asuntos internacionales también es
docente de posgrado del área de
relaciones internacionales en la
universidad militar Nueva Granada en
Bogotá en Colombia ustedes nuestros
televidentes Recuerden que también hacen
parte de esta discusión pueden dejar los
comentarios y todas las preguntas que
ustedes quieran hacer sobre este tema a
través de las redes sociales se las
recuerdo para que participen estamos en
Twitter en Facebook y también en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba
eldegate el debate guión bajo
f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios es numeral el debate f24 no
olviden también que todos los de este
programa también están disponibles en
Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y en
TuneIn ya hay una comunidad grande que
va creciendo a través de la escucha de
nuestros contenidos a través de nuestros
podcast a todos ellos también los
saludamos desde aquí desde el estudio de
France 24
comienzo entonces saludando a Estefany
allí en ciudad de Guatemala y Stephanie
Gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa Y cree usted que este caso
legal tiene pruebas contundentes en
contra de Velázquez y que pueda
trascender Cuál es su opinión bienvenida
gracias buenas Buenas tardes a todas y
todos es un gusto estar con ustedes en
esta tarde creo que antes de entrar
directamente con la respuesta a mí me
gustaría explicar un poco para las
personas que nos seguramente nos están
escuchando en diversos países acerca del
contexto que está viviendo Guatemala
Guatemala está viviendo un grave
contexto en materia de derechos en
materia de Derechos Humanos pero sobre
todo en Casos de corrupción y de falta
de independencia independencia judicial
desde el 2018 como bien ya lo decían
ustedes que
terminan abruptamente el mandato de que
hay que decirlo así el expresidente
Jimmy Morales que también fue señalado
por casos de financiamiento electoral
ilícito de su partido político es quien
decide no renovar el mandato de las
hijas a partir de eso ha venido una
escala de forma muy fuerte y poderosa en
contra quienes lucharon por en contra de
la corrupción ya lo decían ustedes al
principio que más o menos la las Y sí
conoció más de trescientos casos de que
podíamos hablar casos de que donde
estuvieron involucrados grandes
políticos hasta llegar al presidente de
la república diferentes empresarios y
personas que han tenido mucho poder
obtener económico y político en
Guatemala a partir de eso es que en los
últimos años y sobre todo el actual
administración del Ministerio Público y
aquí me voy a detener porque las
actuales autoridades del Ministerio
Público tanto el fiscal que
menciona en este caso como la fiscal
general han sido señalados en diferentes
en diferentes por diferentes organismos
internacionales de que están debilitando
el estado de derecho incluso Estados
Unidos a través de dos listados de la
lista engiel y el otro el listado han
sido
han sido condenados mucho en este
contexto y tengo muy pocos minutos para
abordar el tema puntualmente entonces
hay pruebas contundentes en contra de el
ministro Velázquez que se puede decir al
respecto y ya vamos a abordar diferentes
temas que usted ha puesto allí sobre la
mesa en este contexto que nos estaba
poniendo que le agradezco que lo haga
Así que no se preocupe porque son temas
que vamos a abordar claro no existen
pruebas contundentes entonces parte de
una cacería que hay y una persecución
penal en contra de los ex funcionarios
tanto la del Antiguo fiscalía especial
contra la impunidad Por lo cual esto es
únicamente eh pareciera que es mandar
una advertencia de que se va a perseguir
a todo el que en su momento hizo un buen
trabajo en casos contra la corrupción
vamos a ver ahora la perspectiva desde
Colombia Alejandro allí en Bogotá los
saludo Gracias por estar con nosotros a
esta hora aquí en el debate Y qué se
puede decir de estas acusaciones ya
Stephanie nos dice que claramente no hay
muchas pruebas contundentes en torno a
este caso está siendo Velázquez entonces
simplemente víctima de un caso pantalla
digámoslo así para Guatemala poder
hacer que la mirada se concentre en este
caso y no en todos estos temas de
corrupción que hay al interior del país
que Stephanie Nos estaba explicando
sin duda al ser Velázquez soy ministro
de defensa una figura tan importante
para el gobierno colombiano y no
solamente él sino otros funcionarios
Como por ejemplo David Gaitán era parte
del equipo y que básicamente hoy por hoy
tiene un papel muy relevante en
transparencia internacional en esta ong
que ha condenado estos temas
evidentemente se muestra que es una
cortina de humo ante tantos casos de
corrupción en el país y por otra parte
también es curioso que un acuerdo
policial de cooperación entre Guatemala
y Colombia que se dio el 5 de agosto del
2022 se cancelará tres días después
cuando se dio a conocer que el ministro
de defensa iba a ser Iván Velázquez esto
nos da pruebas contundentes también
sobre lo que se Estaba preparando para
su acusación Alejandro continuó con
usted para hacer la ronda a la inversa
también como parte del contexto es
importante decir o explicar qué tan
cercanas son estas dos naciones qué tan
fluida es la relación entre Guatemala y
Colombia dos países latinoamericanos
pero que están geográficamente distantes
uno en Centroamérica el otro en
Sudamérica hay una buena relación entre
estos países o es tensa ya desde el
principio de estos gobiernos a raíz de
este personaje Velázquez que estuvo
tantos años en Guatemala
Sí realmente hay que recordar debido a
la polarización que estamos encontrando
hoy en América Latina a nivel general
con el tema de gobiernos de izquierda y
de derecha en este caso concreto
recordar que el presidente yamatei
pertenece a una corriente de derecha y
además es heredero contundente del
expresidente Jimmy Morales y se ve en
este contexto además comercialmente
tampoco son muy cercanos netamente las
exportaciones de Colombia a Guatemala
representan un uno coma tres por ciento
Entonces en este momento si se encuentra
una debilidad fuerte que en el pasado
era mucho más cercano cuando vimos que
Colombia participó por allá en el año
1983 en una comisión que se llamó la
comisión de contadora y que estableció
unas necesidades fuertes de unos
posteriores acuerdos llamados estipula
uno y dos en el 87 y en el 86 para
mejorar las condiciones de Guatemala Ya
mi colega Stephanie establec ese
panorama tan fuerte que se encuentra en
Guatemala y que no se ha visto de forma
contundente en las mejoras de la vida de
la población y de la sociedad civil Por
ende es un momento delicado y como lo
vimos también se llamó a consulta a Los
embajadores del lado y lado Estefanía
retomó la conexión con usted y le
pregunto En este contexto que usted nos
hacía al inicio del programa usted habla
que Tal parece que se está tratando de
generar casos contra todas estas
personas que en su momento lucharon
contra esta corrupción que está
enquistada en la realidad de Guatemala
que ya lo vamos a analizar a profundidad
aquí que tanto hay de venganza
revanchismo contra estas personas o
instituciones Cuál es el contexto de
esta no sé si lo podemos llamar como una
campaña en contra de estas personas que
combatieron la corrupción
Sí la verdad es que
pareciera que si es una venganza
sistemática por qué porque en lugar de
que casos que la antigua fe Si la
dejaron eh Muy avanzado digamos en en el
proceso penal a quienes han sido
criminalizados No únicamente en ciertos
funcionarios y exfuncionarios creo que
uno de los casos más insignia y hemos
mencionado yo lo menciono concretamente
Es que la antigua fiscal de la de la
fiscalía especial contra la impunidad
que trabaja directamente con las con la
Virginia la Parra es una mujer que acaba
de ser sido condenada porque denunció a
un juez que estaba haciendo algunas
actuaciones irregulares eso más la
persecución por ejemplo del Antiguo
fiscal de la especial contra la
impunidad con Francisco Sandoval que es
uno de los más de 25 exiliados del
sistema de Justicia que hay en Estados
Unidos actualmente y que han sido
perseguidos no solo únicamente
penalmente sino políticamente Entonces
esto es parte de toda esta estrategia de
venganza de venganza y revanchismo para
quienes en algún momento sirvieron al
país y lo que más llama la atención Es
que no es casualidad que también hay que
entender que Guatemala está en un
contexto electoral donde en este en
medio de este contexto electoral que
empezará en unos días empieza a salir de
esto y todavía si le agregamos a esto
que es hablar acerca de un ministro de
otro país como es el señor Iván
Velázquez en algún momento fue el
comisionado me parece que es totalmente
ilógico rompe reglas de derecho Pero
también es es al final es es meterse en
problemas políticos que quiero aclarar
que yo soy abogada no soy
internacionalista entonces Crea una
atención sin lugar a dudas innecesaria
únicamente Porque estos grupos de poder
políticamente y económicamente que se
vieron investigados en sus intereses
durante el tiempo están haciendo en este
momento
Stephanie continuó con usted y le
preguntó este caso puntual que se suma a
estos casos de corrupción que se han
presentado en Guatemala y que están en
marcha allí estas investigaciones en
Guatemala qué evidencia del sistema
judicial de este país
que Hay ciertos puntos de escape
erosión Qué dice esto entre líneas este
caso puntual de Velázquez esta acusación
está investigación que va a poner en
marcha Guatemala
sí como les decía al principio estamos
viviendo una una crisis Creo que nunca
antes vista creo que tal vez equipara
algunas crisis que se vivió durante el
conflicto armado interno pero la
independencia judicial está siendo
totalmente socavada y para explicarles
una una parte y es que al final todo
esto tiene origen en en otros temas los
magistrados de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia en Guatemala llevan más de dos
de dos años sin ser electos o sea los
que están actualmente ya cumplieron su
función pero el congreso de la república
que también ha tratado de
solaparse y y no avanzar en temas de
Justicia no los ha elegido y son estos
estos magistrados de la Corte Suprema
Corte Suprema de Justicia quienes están
de forma ilegítima que han ayudado a
perseguir jueces y por ejemplo uno de
los uno de los jueces Que conoció este
caso Miguel Ángel Gálvez tuvo que salir
exiliado en Guatemala tenemos más de
diez jueces exiliados que han llevado
este tipo de casos jueces que se
especializaron y por otra parte tenemos
Fiscales la mayoría de la antigua fesi
exiliar está perseguida esto En ningún
es un país que se denomina democrático y
que tiene un sistema de Justicia fuerte
y solvente podría llevarse a cabo es a
veces es es irreal lo que se está
viviendo Alejandro hablemos de la
posición que ha asumido el gobierno
colombiano ha dado un total respaldo
como ya lo decíamos al ministro
Velázquez el presidente ha sido el
presidente colombiano ha sido muy
enfático en estas declaraciones en
respaldar a su funcionario en pedir
respeto hacia el país y hacia la figura
de él como mandatario pero tal vez el
presidente Petro no se ha exhibido un
poco en algunas palabras al mencionar
palabras como decir que esto ya era un
caso de corrupción o que era una
investigación corrupta al tildarlo esto
como un caso de corrupción sin tampoco
tener unas pruebas evidentes ahí el
presidente se está pasando un poco de su
posición y el manejo diplomático que
toca darle a este tipo de temas
sí es importante verlo desde desde la
diplomacia como bien lo anuncia porque
específicamente hemos visto un cruce de
declaraciones ya clarísimo donde el
presidente Jean maten en este caso
particular estableció que el presidente
Petro debía actuar desde la política y
no desde recordar a su pasado
guerrillero es esto se ha convertido en
unos dimes Y diretes como diríamos aquí
en Colombia específicamente Y eso Si
mina las relaciones mina la confianza y
lo que menos se busca es una
fragmentación sobre todo en un gobierno
que completa tampocos meses en este
aspecto concreto y Por ende si es un
llamado como se establece a bajar un
poco la voz también desde las redes
sociales que es un punto más relevante
Por ende si es bastante complejo ese
momento en cuanto a los trinos Por una
parte evidentemente Por supuesto que el
presidente ASUME una postura correcta en
defender a su ministro de defensa y
establecer también como Estados Unidos
ya también se ha comprometido decir que
está en concordancia con lo que opina el
gobierno nacional En este caso concreto
pero sí sería importante utilizar esos
canales diplomáticos que dan las
embajadas y las cancillerías eso es
importante mantener la agenda
diplomática abierta Stephanie Hablemos
del fiscal que está detrás de esta
investigación el fiscal Rafael
corruchiche quién es este personaje en
la escena de la justicia guatemalteca y
de la cena política Guatemala pónganos
en contexto
Gracias
iniciar que el Antiguo fiscal Juan
Francisco Sandoval Pues es despedido de
forma anómala en Guatemala explicar que
la carrera de los fiscales establecen
que son inamovibles y no se pueden
despedir de una forma y de un día para
otro este fiscal había liderado junto
con todo el personal de y con Iván
Velázquez estos casos es es básicamente
despedido Y esa misma noche se tiene que
exiliar y tiene que salir básicamente a
media noche para no ser perseguido a
partir de la de la de la a partir del
despido injustificado y el exilio dejó a
fresco Sandoval pues la fiscal actual
general de Guatemala nombra a Rafael
curuchiche hace un par de meses Estados
Unidos en estas listas que hace la lista
engiel Establece que Rafael corruchichi
es un actor antidemocrático que ha
socavado el estado de derecho y a partir
de esta misma fiscalía para poner en
contexto a la a que nos ven esta
fiscalía que antes perseguía a los
grandes capos evasores políticos de
turno financiamiento electoral ilícito
los casos que últimamente ha sacado son
los casos en contra del ex personal de
la de la fiscalía y de la sisic no
estamos hablando de Virginia la Parra
que se lo mencioné de Iván Velázquez de
David Gaitán ahora que era parte de la
fecha Pero hay una serie de de Fiscales
que tuvieron que salir y son perseguidos
por diferentes temas Entonces ese es el
personal de Rafael curuchiche en el caso
del contexto guatemalteco la mayoría de
personas que conocemos este caso sabemos
que es un actor puesto ahí para
únicamente resguardar ciertos intereses
y básicamente tener una persecución
penal en contra de estos funcionarios
Ese es el personaje que se encuentra hoy
en esa fiscalía que era la más fuerte en
capacidades que tuvo el ministerio
público pero que lamentablemente ya no
existe Estefanía manteniendo en este
marco del contexto de Guatemala
qué tan fuerte está en el tema de la
corrupción a nivel de el gobierno y él
también del empresariado que fueron
justamente dos de las áreas o dos de los
focos que tuvo esta esta comisión
internacional para investigar diferentes
casos detrás de estas investigaciones
detrás de este caso contra Velázquez
puede haber manos importantes del
gobierno y manos también de la sociedad
guatemalteca de las altas esferas de los
empresarios guatemaltecos o o esto parte
desde una iniciativa simplemente desde
la fiscalía
no hay que recordar que históricamente
en el contexto de Guatemala han sido
estos empresarios quien tienen el poder
económico y político en Guatemala verdad
quienes financian partidos políticos y
por ahí voy a utilizar unas palabras que
utilizó Iván Velázquez en su momento el
origen del problema en la parte política
Guatemala era el financiamiento
electoral en su momento
los grandes empresarios como hay en
cualquier país pero en Guatemala todavía
se concentra en menos manos la riqueza
fueron señalados de financiar
electoralmente al expresidente Jimmy
Morales y al partido de gobierno de
turno a partir de esto ha venido un
revanchismo ya no ya no había ninguna
investigación de la que estuvimos
acostumbrados durante varios años los
guatemaltecas y guatemaltecos donde se
nombraba estos empresarios que evadían
impuestos financiaban electoralmente
ilícita contaminaban pedían favores
políticos esto ya no existe esa fe sí
únicamente sirve para hacer esto y eso
llama mucho la atención porque todas
aquellas investigaciones que han habido
de como les una elevación de impuestos
diferenciamiento electoral ya no hubo un
avance en este tipo de investigaciones
Entonces al final la fiscalía la este
fiscal de turno y la fiscal de turno
están sirviendo como un instrumento para
la venganza de todas estas personas
desde el poder político económico que en
algún momento Durante los años o los
mejores años de la fe y fueron
descubiertos y fueron puestos al desnudo
delante de toda la ciudadanía Alejandro
en el contexto colombiano esto hasta
dónde puede llegar para la relación
entre Colombia y Guatemala Qué otros
escenarios posibles puede escalar
Colombia con la idea de defender
la buena honra y el nombre de suministro
como ya dijo el presidente Petro que lo
va a hacer siempre va a defender y estar
del lado de su de su ministro de defensa
Colombia Hasta qué escenarios puede
escalar este desacuerdo esta
discrepancia con Guatemala o sigue
siendo de pronto el diálogo la pieza y
la carta más fácil de jugar por el
momento
por el momento por supuesto esperemos
que se le baje la temperatura que en
este caso el diálogo sea la herramienta
clave pero evidentemente podría
discutirse dentro de organismo
multilaterales como sabemos como el caso
de la organización de los Estados
Americanos la oea o como tiene parte por
haber sido exactamente un organismo
independiente de la ONU de la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas y
donde ya el secretario general Gutiérrez
ha llamado a la conciencia a la
Concordia y a establecer canales de
comunicación esperando por supuesto que
no llegue a conocerse en en estas
instancias que es lo que se espera
porque el camino y el el escenario por
supuesto más radical sería cual la
ruptura de las relaciones diplomáticas
entre ambos países Alejandro y qué
respaldo tiene Velázquez veíamos que
tiene el respaldo del presidente en
cierta forma también de la ONU ya
Estados Unidos también se pronunció en
torno a esta situación y le pidió a los
dos países guardar un poco la compostura
y un poco la temperatura como dice usted
Pero quién respalda Guatemala en esta
denuncia
Sí eso es lo más curioso Digamos si si
otro sería el presidente de los Estados
Unidos porque llamó mucho la atención
que en la era Trump Eso sí es importante
y muy rápido decirlo los fondos para las
y bajaron en este caso concreto por la
buena relación que tenían Guatemala y
los Estados Unidos pero vemos en este
caso concreto como bastante solo a
Guatemala en su Cruzada solitaria
precisamente valga la redundancia en
este caso concreto porque así como lo
comenta la colega Stephanie y lo vemos
en diferentes escenarios las pruebas son
muy grises realmente son débiles y no se
encuentran establecidas para llevar a un
a unos tribunales de Justicia al
ministro Velázquez en este caso concreto
Stephanie retomando el caso de Guatemala
a nivel internacional ya vemos que esta
denuncia y este esta intención de
comenzar esta investigación contra el
ministro colombiano ya está generando
esta crisis diplomática entre Bogotá y
ciudad de Guatemala Estados Unidos
también ya un funcionario de no un alto
nivel político también ya habló sobre
este tema esto que le va a empezar a
generar a Guatemala a nivel
internacional haberse lanzado a hacer
esta investigación de como ustedes dos
han dicho pues tiene unas pruebas que
son muy grises que todavía no son muy
claras como para para poder respaldar el
argumento guatemalteco
claro mire Lamentablemente Estados
Unidos desde hace un par de años
efectivamente como decía el colega desde
la era Trump
de alguna forma ha bajado la condena que
se le ha hecho a los en el caso de los
corruptos en Guatemala verdad los
actores Implicados En actos de
corrupción
Considero que el panorama es bastante es
bastante complejo les digo en el caso
con el contexto guatemalteco estamos por
iniciar un proceso electoral el derecho
penal o la fiscalía están siendo
utilizada como un instrumento de
venganza y de persecución No únicamente
a los funcionarios en este caso como
Iván Velázquez y los funcionarios de la
de la de la y de la fesino sino también
a periodistas Defensores de Derechos
Humanos Entonces el el espacio o el
contexto es muy complicado
Pues nos tocará a todos los
guatemaltecos y guatemaltecos de alguna
forma en sus diferentes manifestaciones
hacer un un alto todo esto Esto no es
únicamente ahorita está escalando a
nivel internacional porque la elabora
ahora
de un funcionario de otro país un alto
funcionario de otro país pero esta
persecución que se está dando y que se
ha dado en los últimos años en contra de
todos estos personajes que les dije ha
aumentado y haya un escalado profunda
deteriorando el estado de derecho y pues
creo que para nadie de las personas que
nos ven es es Es un secreto de Guatemala
los años en los últimos años como la
corrupción ha permeado toda la
institución pública y como eso acababa
el estado de derecho justamente para
llevar mi siguiente Pregunta Stephanie
qué tan enquistada está la corrupción en
la realidad guatemalteca sabemos que la
corrupción es un tema transversal para
toda América Latina Esto no es exclusivo
de este país centroamericano es un mal
que afecta a todas los estados
latinoamericanos pero Guatemala Parece
ser un caso muy particular sobre todo
por los hechos que se están viviendo que
usted ha mencionado en cuanto a la
persecución a los periodistas
persecución a políticos a opositores y a
personas que trabajaron o son parte de
estas comisiones para investigar casos
de corrupción
como Bien dicen ustedes el tema
corrupción es un tema de América Latina
pero en Guatemala
como está conformado el estado desde
partidos políticos hasta toda la
institucionalidad ahora con la captación
casi total de la mayoría de
institucionalidad que está en manos de
en manos del
en manos de de gente cercana al gobierno
o del ejecutivo de turno que también ha
sido señalado y recordemos que los
últimos tres gobiernos no voy a
mencionar los otros porque también ha
sido pero en los últimos tres gobiernos
de Guatemala en los casos de corrupción
han sido muy altos y no veamos los casos
de Alejandro yamatei como una minera
rusa que supuestamente revise recibió
pagos por favor y de licencias que la
fiscalía nunca investigó el expresidente
Jimmy Morales salpicado hasta su hermano
y su hijo por tema de de corrupción el
expresidente Héctor Pérez Molina que
acaba de ser condenado a quince años de
cárcel pero que todavía tienes procesos
abiertos y menciono esto porque estamos
hablando de las personas que dirigen el
país eso creo que ya nos dice mucho y
por ahí transparencia internacional y
otros organismos han mencionado que
muchas veces el presupuesto del
presupuesto entero del país el 40% sirve
para corrupción Entonces eso creo que
nos dice bastante en que en qué posición
estamos actualmente dice mucho sobre la
situación de allí de Guatemala Alejandro
en el contexto colombiano volvemos otra
vez a la realidad de este país hay que
decir que este es un gobierno nuevo
lleva apenas cinco meses en el poder que
tanto han cerrado filas en torno al
ministro allí en Bogotá no solamente el
presidente que ya lo mencionábamos pero
a nivel político que tanto respaldado al
ministro Velázquez y defienden la acción
que realizó él durante sus años en
Guatemala ha habido apoyo del
empresariado de otros sectores políticos
en torno al ministro
sí hay que recordar en este caso
particular y para los televidentes que
Velázquez de igual manera estableció una
relación bastante complicada en sus años
con el con el gobierno del presidente
Álvaro Uribe entonces también hay
algunas versiones que han establecido
que potencialmente dado podría ser una
jugada desde la derecha en este caso
particular la relación no tan positiva
que ha tenido Iván Velázquez como
ministro de defensa con el estamento
militar de igual manera también se ha
visto un poco fracturada Entonces es un
momento también delicado en el término
nacional desde la imagen y desde lo que
ha sido esta estos temas de juicio por
sus actuaciones en Guatemala sin embargo
hasta el momento por parte del
empresariado se ha recibido unas
potencialidades y unos documentos y una
imagen bastante positiva en este caso
concreto es a nivel general si es
importante decirlo es bastante el apoyo
por parte de la cúpula
eso en cuanto al al apoyo hacia
Velázquez Pero qué ha dicho Velázquez
sobre este tema allí en Bogotá
sí en este caso concreto Velázquez ha
hablado específicamente como la pregunta
que abre el programa que es una
persecución que viene dado precisamente
por la corrupción que ya hemos visto a
lo largo de varios gobiernos en
Guatemala y que él por supuesto tiene
las pruebas y las evidencias que en
ningún momento de su periodo durante lo
que estuvo en la sisic cometió ningún
caso grave de corrupción y que
evidentemente tampoco recibió dinero de
odebreck que es una de las acusaciones
de la fiscalía en este caso particular
de su conciencia está totalmente limpia
Estefany allí en Guatemala usted ya nos
ha puesto muy en claro Cuál es el la
situación que se está viviendo Pero a lo
largo de
la los años en los que estuvo la activa
allí en Guatemala qué tanto avanzó
Guatemala en su lucha contra la
corrupción había avances evidentes yo he
dado algunas cifras de los casos y de
las personas y de y de tienes que
desmantelaron Pero esto evidenció un
cambio Claro en Guatemala fue fue un
avance significativo todos estos avances
que yo estaba mencionando en al inicio
del programa en el contexto general
Sí gracias yo creo que se avanzó en
varios temas lo primero es que durante
la época de la sigue digamos
simbólicamente se evidenció como lo que
ya sabíamos pero que no habíamos visto
de forma contundentes como estas redes
del Poder y estos cuerpos clandestinos
de seguridad tenían cooptado al estado
como tal Y cómo es que lo veía un botín
y quien llegaba la administración
pública pareciera que en cualquier
puesto del de diputados hasta
trabajadores
llegaban al llegaban a la administración
Pública para enriquecerse únicamente y
no para servir como debería ser
cualquier funcionario o funcionario en
el mundo creo que eso es suficiente
también se avanzó en aprobar leyes
específicas en materia de Justicia que
aún permanecen también se avanzó en
crear pues juzgados especializados se
creó también a transparentar y darle
sobre todo a la ciudadanía a las
personas que estamos digamos fuera de
este fuera de la Administración pública
a tener una esperanza que sí se podía
tener un estado diferente que sí se
podría tener una administración pública
que para la gente y no que únicamente
llegara para saquear eso y el mensaje
contundente que se envía Yo creo que el
caso más simbólico o el más conocido es
meter a la cárcel investigar a un
presidente de turno que llegó para
enriquecerse de forma excepcional Porque
si pueden leer en internet el caso de
Otto Pérez Molina y de la ex
vicepresidente Y de todos los ministros
que literalmente se llegaron a
enriquecer y y y dejar por un lado el
trabajo creo que esos el legado que
persiste las de la simple va a creer que
sí se puede pero que es necesario que al
final toda la ciudadanía pues lo pueda
exigir vamos llegando ya al bloque final
de el programa y quiero hacer las
conclusiones de lo que puede venir para
este caso en torno a dos aristas
diferentes la primera en Estefanía
Alejandro en torno al caso de Velázquez
puntualmente qué tanto puede entonces
avanzar esto en los próximos días que
otra carta bajo la manga puede sacar la
justicia guatemalteca para seguir
avanzando en este caso y de el otro lado
quiero que analicen también la situación
diplomática la atención diplomática
entre estos dos países que tanto va a
escalar y hasta dónde puede llegar esta
esta discrepancia entre Bogotá y ciudad
de Guatemala comienzo entonces con
Alejandro en la capital colombiana para
esta conclusión adelante
Sí yo pensaría en el caso particular que
realmente este caso no tiene asidero por
varios casos en varios momentos en
particular la falta de unas pruebas
contundentes el apoyo por supuesto y
restricto por parte del presidente de
Colombia y lo que ha sido el mensaje
también por parte de organismos
multilaterales como la Organización de
las Naciones Unidas de la inmunidad
diplomática que existe por los
funcionarios eso por parte de de una
constante lo segundo en este caso
particular hasta donde subirá Esperamos
que no más de la atención que estamos
viviendo estos días pero evidentemente
podría llevar una ruptura de relaciones
diplomáticas entre Bogotá y ciudad de
Guatemala lo cual sería la primera
crisis de gobierno de Gustavo Petro en
netamente cinco meses de gobierno su
primera crisis internacional su primera
crisis en la región de América Latina y
ya lo está haciendo frente lo hemos
visto a lo largo de los últimos días
Estefany su conclusión en
aristas diferentes sobre el tema
adelante
sí como el colega no tiene mayor asidero
este caso es parte de esta esta venganza
que hay en contra este personal es
totalmente
de forma incorrecta Cómo se ha manejado
el caso cuando se escucha al fiscal
curruchiche hablar del caso como
conocemos los latinoamericanos habla de
una forma cantinflesca en donde no
establece Cuál es el Cuáles son los
motivos reales o los que pudo haber
incurrido el ex comisionado y ahora
ministro Velázquez entonces me parece
que es innecesario toda esta crisis que
se está viviendo provocada provocada por
por personal de la fiscalía que está
señalada de graves casos de corrupción
entonces esperaría yo que terminara la
mejor forma posible Y de alguna forma
entender al al presidente Petro en
defender a algunos algunos ministros y
esperamos sobre todo por el bien de la
ciudadanía tanto guatemalteca como la
colombiana que esto no pase a mayores
cosas
Pues a Stephanie y a Alejandro les
agradezco mucho por haber hecho este
análisis de esta atención entre Colombia
y Guatemala en torno a estas acusaciones
contra el ministro colombiano Iván
Velázquez vamos a ver qué sucede en este
caso en los próximos días gracias por
haber estado con nosotros en el programa
En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos a ustedes la sintonía por
haber estado con nosotros la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Luis
Fernando Montes y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera sigan con nosotros siga con
France 24
[Música]